[Music]
hi it's Michele from lab love and beauty
science here chemistry PhD skin candor
and oxygen breather today we're going to
talk about oxygen masks how do they work
and what do they do apart from making
you look fluffy if you like this sort of
video please give it a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel and make sure
you click on the notification bell so
you don't miss any of my videos let's
talk about Archer now sure first up what
exactly is an oxygen mask oxygen masks
are products which come out of the
bottle like a gel but they start
bubbling with oxygen gas after you put
them on your skin for a bit as you wait
your skin gets covered in tickly bubbles
and you sort of start to look like a
cloud they're pretty darn entertaining
lots of brands have come out with oxygen
masks there's brands like bliss Peter
Thomas Roth dr. Brad Asik
Sephora and philosophy how exactly do
they get the oxygen into the bottle
these oxygen products work a lot like
soda water gas gets dissolved in the
water under pressure so for example
carbon dioxide gas is in soda water
this gas gets released when the pressure
drops so when you open the soda water
bottle
unlike carbon dioxide oxygen doesn't
really dissolve that well in water
instead you have solvents in these
products called perfluorocarbons there's
a stable unreactive carbon-based
compounds that have lots of fluorine on
them compared to water they can dissolve
about 20 times more oxygen and they've
been investigated for use in artificial
blood
these perfluorocarbons can be mixed with
the oxygen and then sealed in a
pressurized bottle so when it comes out
the oxygen will start fizzing out slowly
like a bubbly soft drink if you have a
thicker product you might not even need
a pressurized bottle the thickness of
the product can trap the oxygen inside
the oxygen gas only comes out when you
massage it over your skin it's a little
bit like pop rocks there are a lot of
different pet fluorocarbon products in
these oxygen masks the most common ones
are probably per Florida colon and
methyl per floor butyl ether but pretty
much anything in the ingredients list
with the word per floor in it will be a
puffer a carbon there are also some
oxygen masks that get oxygen from
hydrogen peroxide composing so for
example philosophise austrian peels are
like this you'll want to keep these
products away from dark fabrics because
peroxide will bleach them but the ones
that have perfluorocarbons will be safe
I'm using this bubble purifying and
charcoal face sheet mask the key
ingredients in this there are some
humectants so dye propylene glycol and
glycerine
there's also methyl per fluid butyl
ether methyl per floor acid butyl ether
and these two ingredients will dissolve
the oxygen and make it foam up again
when I put this on there are also some
other cool ingredients in this like
centella and a bunch of other fruit
extracts as well
you
this is massively sped up I forgot to
Robert to activate the bubbles before
putting it on and I got bored so I only
left it on for seven minutes instead of
10 to 15 if you want the full cloud
experience you should do both of these
things so what exactly is the point of
having oxygen in these products one of
the reasons is because the amount of
oxygen in your skin decreases as you get
older it also decreases if you smoke or
if you get a lot of UV exposure from the
Sun it's estimated that there's a
quarter less oxygen in your skin by the
time you're 30 and only half of it
remains by the time you're 40 you need
oxygen in your skin to produce collagen
so it's possible that if you don't have
enough oxygen then your collagen levels
will drop and you'll end up with thinner
saggy
duller skin and wrinkles there's been
some research that found that extra
oxygen can help with wound healing and
it increases something called the lag
Rijn this is a protein in your skin
that's important for keeping a healthy
skin barrier oxygen could also
potentially help kill acne bacteria
there was an animal study as well which
found that oxygen reduced wrinkles
caused by UV the problem with oxygen is
that there haven't been any convincing
studies done on humans about how it can
help your skin there's also a potential
side effect which is that the extra
oxygen could increase the amount of
reactive oxygen species or RS in your
skin these oxidants are important for
lots of biological processes but if you
have too many they can attack and damage
the proteins and DNA in your skin and
this leads to premature aging I've
talked about oxidative stress before in
my video on antioxidants and skincare a
few wound healing studies have looked at
whether this side effect is significant
and they found out it wasn't
[Music]
so now that we know that oxygen can be
good for your skin the question is is
there really enough in these products
that can get into your skin to make a
difference there are a few studies on
using oxygenated perfluorocarbons for
wound healing and there's also been one
very basic one on whether or not it can
reduce wrinkles but these studies were
all done using topical gels which are
things that you leave on your skin not
using wash off products like these masks
so in these studies there was probably
more oxygen getting into the skin most
studies that have been done on oxygen
and wound healing used other methods for
getting oxygen into the skin like oxygen
producing bandages rather than
perfluorocarbons the fact that you see
all these bubbles coming up when you use
an oxygen mask could mean that most of
the oxygen is going into the air and not
into your skin so in other words they're
not really getting to where they can
make a difference but the tickling
feeling does make a feel like it's doing
more the bubbling action could also
potentially loosen dirt so the product
can get deeper into your pore and then
the bubbles can help unclog it sort of
like how baking soda can unclog a drain
so I think overall until there's be more
studies done on these oxygen masks
they're mostly just a fun product that
might help you clean your face better
but I think that unlikely to have any
anti-aging benefits
I hope you like this video if you
enjoyed it please give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to my channel for more
videos like this you can also follow me
on Instagram and check out my blog for
more about beauty science let me know
what else you want me to talk about in
the comments and I'll see you next time